sí muy buenos días pues los pasajeros
continúan llegando aquí estamos en la
terminal 2e donde salen la mayoría de
los vuelos internacionales aún los que
van fuera de la unión europea y
efectivamente pues hay que presentar los
diferentes documentos para demostrar que
se tiene un motivo de fuerza mayor para
salir desde francia hacia un país de la
unión europea o incluso para entrar a
francia desde un país fuera de la unión
europea hablamos con algunos de los
viajeros un hombre que va a senegal a
visitar a su padre quien está muy
enfermo que nos explicaba que tuvo que
pedirle al médico de su papá que le
hiciera un certificado médico explicando
que la salud de su señor padre pues
estaba desmejorando y que por eso
necesitaba la compañía de su hijo y
también hablamos con otras personas que
viajan hacia argelia porque han
conseguido un trabajo allí estos son
algunos digamos de los motivos de fuerza
mayor que permiten a las personas salir
de francia con destino a países fuera de
la unión europea pero no para todo el
mundo está muy claro y algunos viajeros
están un poquito perdidos nos decían
algunos de los funcionarios
el aeropuerto y lo cierto es que hay dos
tiempos de control una parte de las
aerolíneas y luego será la policía en
migración la que decida si están
mostrando o no un motivo de fuerza mayor
por ahora no se sabe hasta cuándo estará
en vigor esta medida
natalia gracias por información buen día